[Music]
ho ho ho it's not Thanksgiving yet
I meant it's Thanksgiving it's not
Christmas yeah and it's not ho ho ho
it's quack quack quack it's gobble
gobble gobble oh man what goes clock or
chicken what is Luca go
how does Luca go where do you go
[Music]
all right it is Thanksgiving today and
we have the Chan Clan here I'm at the
grandparents on Luca watch Luca is on
mommy making pie watch yeah Tiff's
making pie she's making apple pie I got
some collard greens going on in here and
I got some prime rib out here that looks
beautiful that is going on
five hours we're almost done almost so
I'm on prime rib watch right Luca you're
on mommy watch and Diana here is on
Bruno watch
ES
[Laughter]
those trying to eat dog food
so this is I know he will so Zoe has
never really been around dogs in fact he
hasn't really been around any other
animals other than Maya so this is very
new surprise he's like ballsy enough to
just be right here he doesn't know the
dangers
all right
[Music]
so it seems to me that we always do
Thanksgiving pretty big these days we
always have to do oysters now I don't
know what year we began doing this but
we have 150 oysters here we're going to
be sucking throughout the night there's
more back there 150 oysters you got the
prime rib roast and then we also got
something extra special today we got
some Kai wagyu as well so we are going
all in on some fancy foods so what is
kind of wagyu Kai wagyu it is beautiful
marbled wagyu oh my goodness
look at this this is A5 Japanese web you
rib eye steak I cannot wait to bite into
that this is gonna be like butter look
at all the marbling I'm already salad
Australian wagyu Denver State look at
that beautiful
all right Mr Isaac what are we doing
today
I don't know why I'm talking like that
so we have been doing oysters for a good
how many how many years of voices have
we done yeah like three years four years
it's a tradition yeah it is a tradition
we all have too many this time well we
thought Luke are you trying to fully
Bruno come sit down baby baby
so yeah we've been doing this for like
about three years I think everyone in
this family has struck a good amount of
oysters in we're pretty dang good at it
getting faster at least we got better
knives we upgraded our uh yes we have
upgraded Isaac's already got into this
one we forgot to lay out the ice but
we're doing that right now you want to
keep the oysters and cold yeah we're
experts yeah
we only got through a fraction of these
yeah well we're supposed to start eating
them yesterday for some reason we didn't
get started with the oysters we got too
tired or something yeah
[Music]
traumatizing our bodies and then we
wanted to play our games that was very
important
you lose ice in the back move your hands
if you Flinch you lose okay yeah
I'm recording your face
oh shoot he's a guy
no he won
that's a great job I think and if the
shirt it even touched my skin yeah he
actually has his back so curved
on purpose to walk me through it how do
we do this all right so first thing we
did you stab it through this like um
this opening right here I like to call
that the butthole the butt yeah you dig
your way through and then you start
shuffling it side to side so I need to
get a little more deeper deeper in the
butt for the rough one and I hate the
non-cooperative ones no pressure the
camera's on I'm good now you start
twisting there we go nice
beautiful I love that sound but then
[Music]
yeah we might want to oh Jesus did you
see that yeah that was scary no I'm okay
[Music]
all right cool you're good guys you're
done
out
okay
big shout out to Kai wagyu for sending
us some Japanese A5 wagyu Cuts they made
for the best appetizers for a
Thanksgiving meal smoking a mouse
make sure to go to the link in our
description and check them out use code
Tiff case10 to get 10 off your orders
[Music]
that James Bond stuff right here this is
my first time eating caviar
um
that's what caviar tastes like I need to
put it on the steak
put on strike this is how you do caviar
tastes like fish butter
[Applause]
oh this is the Isaac's idea
I feel so fancy
because you've become quite the uh
professional pie maker I know it's my
third pie looks so proud of you Mommy
you're so proud of mommy are you like oh
yeah
hey in there Lucas we speak together
[Music]
a Race Against Time he's got his bedtime
coming up we want him to eat with us for
Thanksgiving for his first Thanksgiving
meal we're gonna make it all right we
got Matt oh no we're not mac and cheese
that we got mashed potatoes prime rib
collard greens mac and cheese Happy
Thanksgiving with baby here's your
Thanksgiving meal your first Happy
Thanksgiving look at this a beef and
veggie and potato oh my God all right
Happy Thanksgiving everybody
you all I am thankful for everyone here
as well and for this Bountiful food amen
I'm thankful for
family
2022. Fast and Furious all right I am
thankful for family everyone is here
together
who is that
nobody say family and he said it sounded
like family yeah I sound like someone
spoke you know we do this every year and
I feel like sometimes we take it for
granted that you know we meet a Phil
often but like you know it's very you
know every moment is very fleeting too
at the same time so I'm thankful for
that that we can meet up constantly
every year and share a good meal yeah
multiple good meals we had some good
meals the last couple days the first
communities were so freaking good
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
very well said good job Luca I'm
thankful that Luca finally is here with
us for the first his first Thanksgiving
dinner with Barbara and he's so enjoying
his beef yeah
[Music]
I'm very thankful for my love for 50
years so in a month we are going to
celebrate our 50 years anniversary
December 55. last year we thought his
Five-O but we need counseling
we jumped the gunman this is my first uh
our first Thanksgiving
amen Thanksgiving amen
[Music]
this is the first time I did the egg
wash and I think that's why I kind of
got a little burnt I like it I like the
little color that you put in there oh I
also sprinkled sugar on top so maybe
that's what burnt no I'm not confident
right now you guys who wants apple pie
[Music]
look at me you're struggling I was
struggling we couldn't
all righty we are now doing presents
it's Christmas time now it's Christmas
because at the time has been Christmas
with us because we're going to Dallas
for Christmas and we're not traveling
with these so I like how beautiful rap
they are yep tip did such an amazing job
she did not hire a professional to do
this she did this herself
this is the quickest we've ever shoved
Thanksgiving and science Christmas time
now well I mean I've already decorated
the home for Christmas true as soon as
Thanksgiving is over that's Christmas
time exactly potatoes
that's true November 1st is Christmas
whatever our local grocery store says
it's Christmas when they bring out their
stuff it's Christmas
[Music]
[Music]
that's the best part
what is this something for bougie people
you guys are bougie people are you
considered bougie you guys are the
hardest people to shop for that's funny
though is different the hand is this is
really nice this is we we can't just
leave this in the dishwasher
[Music]
[Laughter]
it looks like a vibrator but it's a
massage thing from Brookstone with an
actual vibrator though oh okay I thought
you're saying as an actual vibrator I'm
like that's hilarious how come I didn't
know this because
let's just move this thing out the way
too bulky um
it's a vibrator
[Laughter]
all right Isaac's next
yes
vibrator
I've actually been eating this I know
oh you scare me the vibrator comes from
hey hey get a room
oh yeah the same one all right it is the
next morning time for Luca to open his
present first gift ever his very first
present who's ever unwrapping in his
entire life yeah it's the placement when
you're eating food you know you rip it
off yeah
good job
it's okay you're gonna have to get used
to cheering
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
your first present you think he's ready
for that she can do it you can do it
yeah that's your first present my baby
you have a second one you ready
to work
oh the magnetic wood stacker rocket
[Music]
look at this do we have a brave soul to
walk the walk
okay oh my baby I'm so proud of you
[Music]
he caught himself
foreign
[Music]